Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This will be my brand new Star Wars
skeleton crew trailer breakdown.
We had a bunch of new footage,
a bunch of Easter eggs and connections
to Ahsoka in The Mandalorian.
It's set during the same time period.
It's meant to be part of the Mando verse,
so I'll explain
how everything is connected.
If you're brand new to the channel.
Of course I'll do episodes four
when it releases next year.
Originally it was supposed to come
at the end of this year, 2023,
but then Disney basically
pushed all the Marvel and Star Wars series
just a little bit,
so everything is just spread out more.
Now, this sounds like it's going
to premiere in the first half of 2024.
They didn't give an exact release date,
so I'm assuming first half of 2024.
John Watch was the person
who created the series.
He actually said
that he was talking to Jon Favreau
about creating it
while they were filming Spider-Man
No Way Home, because most of you remember
him from all the Spider-Man films.
And Jon Favreau plays
Happy Hogan in those Spider-Man films.
So naturally,
that's the Star Wars connection.
That's how Jon Watts
wound up doing a Star Wars series.
This is him introducing the actual series
Sorry we can't be there today.
We're actually at home right now
shooting the spaceships for the show
with the one and only Jon on.
I did not agree to be on camera.
Oh, Jon.
But don't worry.
Even though we can be there,
we have someone way better.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the one and only Jude Law.
Oh, but as you can see,
Jude Law is the main character.
It's about a group of kids, though,
in the outer rim who get swept up
in a larger adventure with Jude Law's
character in the Tone of Stranger Things
meets Stephen King, Stand By Me
meets Goonies in the Star Wars universe.
They also referenced a Bible
on the classic Steven Spielberg
Amblin movies Group of Kids getting into
in solving a bunch of problems
like they cause a lot of the problems
that they themselves
wind up having to solve,
especially the inciting incident
that gets them lost
in what seems like the unknown regions.
Because one of the big differences
with this series
is that it's going to a new part of space
in the Star Wars galaxy
that they've never visited before,
which I believe
is meant to be the unknown regions.
That's basically
where Grand Admiral Thrawn
got lost with Ezra Bridger
at the end of Star Wars Rebels, where he's
returning from during the Ahsoka series
in The Mandalorian series.
Like I just did a big Ahsoka trailer video
where we saw Grand Admiral Thrawn
returning from the unknown regions
and he becomes this big threat
and they're doing a version
of the original Thrawn trilogy, Heir
to the Empire in the Star Wars universe.
During this part of the Mandalorian
timeline, started hearing whispers
about Theron's return
as heir to the Empire.
Skeleton
Crew is meant to be a big part of that.
But Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni,
who are sort of like the overseers
of this entire part of the timeline,
they're executive producers
on all the different theories.
They said the skeleton crew
characters will not cross over
on The Mandalorian Season three.
There might be some crossover
with the Ahsoka series
just because of the overarching
connections with the Thrawn plot.
It sounds like they wind up getting lost
in the same area
of space in the unknown regions
where Thrawn got lost.
But the basic idea
is that the little girls,
as you see in some of the trailer footage,
find something
the Grand Shards Pirates are doing.
Look, they see something
that's going down on their way home
in wind up running from them.
Vane comes back and Shard comes back.
The same group of pirates that we saw
in The Mandalorian,
Mando and Bo-Katan fighting.
They chase them down, trying to kill them
in order to escape.
They jump the ship and head to the unknown
regions without hyperspace coordinates.
And it sounds like that's
how they get lost.
And they basically have
to find their way back home.
Kind of like Star Trek Voyager.
If you didn't watch Star Trek Voyager,
basically the ship got lost in
a completely different part of the galaxy,
like a completely different quadrant in
it is slowly make their way home.
In the footage they released,
you can see the characters
staring at a bunch of star charts
trying to make their way home slowly.
Jude Law's character is kind of
like the David Harbor hopper of the group
trying to take care of the kids
while they try to get home,
trying to keep them
from killing themselves,
basically
because they are a group of little kids.
Honestly,
I was like six years old when this
this galaxy, this this
world gripped me, blew my mind.
And I feel like I've been in preparation
ever since.
So it was a breeze.
It was a it was a total pleasure.
And I think one of the highlights
was working with the incredible
talented people behind the scenes.
When you see that that the drawings
and the and the animals
and the aliens
and yeah, it was a true dream come true.
I don't want to pretend
that they haven't fully explained what
this group does that gets them
tied up in the larger Thrawn plot.
But it sounds like whatever it is,
it happens in the unknown regions
and has something to do
with the imperial remnants.
Like we know Green shards, pirates
are connected to the Imperial remnant.
They're going to address that during
the Mandalorian season three Episode seven
In the Episode eight finale, like
they'll tie back into the larger plot.
People have been complaining
that we don't really know
what's going on in The Mandalorian
this season.
What is the plot about this season?
They basically answer that
in the last two episodes
of The Mandalorian Season three,
they're supposed to be pretty big bangers.
My full Episode seven video
will post this week after they release it,
but it sounds like the little kids witness
something that the Pirates are doing
that has something to do
with the Imperial Remnant.
With Thrawn,
they get lost in the unknown regions.
Then while they're lost in the unknown
regions,
they also find things that connect
to the larger Thrawn plot.
Like you see them staring at this ancient
fragment of a map here with all this
riding on it, most of the trailer footage
they released is kind of vague.
It doesn't
really give you a ton of the story,
just kind of gives you a once
in front of the characters.
Like this is what everybody looks like.
This is kind of the vibe of the series.
They probably won't release
a longer proper story trailer
until we get much,
much closer to the episode.
It's actually coming out probably
right after the Ahsoka series comes out.
The actual trailer starts
with a Droid teacher in the main
character's kids class.
We meet the kids there for them.
This first one is Robby Cobo Connor's.
They didn't say what the character's
names were.
We just saw who the actors were.
They jumped to a for a shot of two
of the other characters, the female
characters, kids talking to each other
with Catriona Crowder in Ryan.
Kiera Armstrong,
who plays the Gwen character.
She's meant to be
the daughter of Jude Law's character.
The only reason why we know her name is
Gwen is because Jude Law's character
literally says it in the trailer.
She questions her friend
whether or not she wants to do something
more exciting with their lives,
like it's really boring on their planet.
Here.
The scene is meant to be in the same vein
as Luke Skywalker in a New Hope,
complaining that he'll never find a way
off this rock tattooing, complaining
he never get to do anything interesting,
dreaming of having space adventures
and just like Luke
Skywalker gets swept up in the rebellion,
the larger galactic Civil War
against the Empire with Obi-Wan Kenobi,
these kids go through something similar
getting swept up
in this part of the timeline.
But the conflict is against grand Admiral
Thrawn in the Imperial Remnant in Moff
Gideon
You see them break into someone's workshop
after walking through the forest here.
The next scene is at night in another
part of the city, with Jude Law's
character coming home, telling
what seems like his daughter Gwen.
The footage is kind of janky
potato quality
that she needs to be doing her
homework, is trying to check on her,
looking through their house for her,
and the intercut
with footage of his daughter
Gwen, and her friend
running through the woods,
crying out for him
like she's running from the pirates.
Remember,
this is gory in shards, group of vein in.
It sounds like the inciting incident
that causes them to all jumped the ship
and into the unknown regions without a map
is the girl sees something shady.
The green shards
men are doing on their way home
from their little field trip
through the woods in.
The pirates come after them and they run.
They jump to a scene of their ship
flying across an asteroid.
This is the main ship during the series,
they didn't say
what the name of the ship is, but it looks
like a totally new design on the ship.
You see the four kids
and Jude Law's character.
You notice
that one of the kids isn't or tall.
And that's the same race
that Max Ribeau was from Job Jabba's Band.
They were also featured alive
and well during the book of Boba Fett.
Later in the timeline
playing in the club in the city, there's
another scene of the Gwen character
getting ready to depart their ship,
going to a different planet.
This scene seems like their ship space
dock in another part of the unknown
regions.
They jump to like a new part of space.
Wherever this place winds up
being the area they jump to
is meant to be somewhere.
Never visited in the Star Wars
universe before.
Which is why I say
the unknown regions like the place
where Thrawn basically got lost.
There are a bunch of other alien
ships docked there.
This is Carrie Condon
back on the home planet
that they actually took off
from playing one of the major
characters of the series,
telling Sun a Pemba Base character,
We don't know their names.
Something is wrong.
We don't really know what their connection
is to Jude Law's character
or the other kids.
They might be related to one of the kids.
Carrie Condon, also an amazing actress
some of you might remember her is
Iron Man's Air Friday two
food Jet failing
Flight systems, Compromised
Crowd.
This scene is of the kids
using the docking mechanism to leave
their ship in what is probably them
stepping onto the new alien planet
in the unknown regions
or one of the new plants
they travel to notice that there's a Droid
character behind them.
They haven't revealed
what the droids name is
or who's playing it,
but there's a long standing tradition
in the Star Wars
movies and series
that everyone has some kind of
droid companion or their Droid
main characters like on The Mandalorian.
He has R five now
and previously they had IG 11.
This is another scene
of the Ortolan character on the ship.
This scene is in an office building.
The architecture is the same building.
Carrie
Condon's character is in with Tunney.
It's a wider shot of their officers.
Not sure what they're actually
doing in this office or what they do
at the office, but there's another droid
watching over them.
The voiceover is coming from Ton Day
telling Carrie Condon's character
They need to find the kids.
So that's why I say
they're probably on the planet
that the kids took off from with Jude Law,
and it sounds like they'll bounce back
and forth between
these different locations in the galaxy.
Like it won't just follow
Jude Law's character
in the Kids into the unknown regions.
You also come back to the regular part
of the galaxy where they're from.
This scene is
you see the kids running through
what looks like an alien marketplace
on one of the foreign planes
that they travel to
in the unknown regions, like they're
exploring a totally new planet
that they never been to before.
Don't touch anything.
This is Banes character
coming back from The Mandalorian.
Goran starts pirates
picking up a gun off the floor,
looking at
what seems like the two little girls.
And it seems like it's connected
to that earlier scene in the trailer
when Gwen and her friend stumble
into the pirates conducting business
and then they chase them down
trying to kill them.
This is just another scene of Carrie
Condon in that same office building.
I'm not sure which planet this is,
but the scene of the main ship
is flying over the city here.
Notice
that they have a Rex star tour droid.
There are actually a bunch of them
featured
on The Mandalorian recently
when they went into the Droid Bar.
This seems like one of Gordon Shards
other pirates working with Bane.
This scene is a little too potato quality,
but it seems like they find a droid
that's broken down, deactivated.
It might be the same droid that joins them
on their mission to make it home.
They might just wind up repairing it.
It becomes part of their crew. There.
There are a couple other scenes
that they released here like this.
Looks like they find an ancient map
fragment, probably wind up using it as
part of the information to find their way
home, but the information is incomplete.
Notice all the symbols on it
are written in Arabic.
That's the main language of the Star Wars
universe.
So you see it
written all over the place in the movies.
In all the series.
I can't make out the figures
at the bottom of the fragment,
but in this other scene,
like you see them in the same room
with all these maps and star charts
strewn out all over the place,
it just seems like they try to
piece their way back home slowly
because there are no good complete
maps of the unknown regions,
which is why they can't easily plot
a hyperspace route back home.
That's also why
Thrawn was lost in the unknown regions
for the entirety of the original trilogy,
why he wasn't around during a new Hope
Empire Strikes Back of Return of the Jedi
because he had no star charts to jump back
home.
You also notice that Robert Timothy
Smith's character here in the motion
capture suit,
he's playing the ortolan character.
Just because this is behind the scenes,
they haven't tuned it up
in post-production.
So you're not seeing the special effects.
It looks like Kyrie on a crowder's
character might be blind
and she's wearing an eye prosthetic.
It totally looks like
it's inspired by Geordi.
La Forge is visor on Star Trek
The Next Generation.
This is just a behind
the scenes shot of them on the volume,
but the scene they're filming
might be on one of these alien planets
just because of the terrain
underneath them.
This is just a scene of Jude Law
between scenes with the kids
on the bridge of their new ship
with him in the pilot's chair.
So like I said, a little bit of stranger
things mix with Stand By Me, mixed
with a little bit of Star Trek Voyager,
like we're
lost in an unknown part of the galaxy
and we slowly have to make our way home
because Jon Favreau, Dave
Filoni said that the characters
would not appear on The Mandalorian.
I'm not expecting to see
a bunch of Easter eggs in the last
two episodes of The Mandalorian Season
three for Skeleton Crew.
We might see more Easter eggs
during Ahsoka, so I will do more
Skeleton Crew videos as we get more
Easter eggs later this year, More footage.
But the larger plan
is that because of the Thrawn movie,
the Heir to the Empire, Star Wars movie
that they're doing,
where all these Mando verse shows
will cross over the Skeleton Crew
characters, Jude Law's character,
The Kids will also crossover
with The Mandalorian,
with the Ahsoka characters
when they'll have their final battle
against Thrawn.
Dave Filoni confirmed that he's going
to be the one that's making that movie.
It is based on the expanded
Universe Original Thrawn trilogy,
which is why I say Heir to the Empire.
That's going to be the name of the movie.
They have a murderer's row of directors
talent working on the series.
Like I said,
John was one of the executive producers
directed on the series, wrote
a lot of the series.
They have the Daniels brothers who just
did everything everywhere all at once.
Isaac Lee Chung, who just did Minari.
Also,
he just directed The Mandalorian Season
three Episode three Sounds like
that was a bit of a test run for him.
They have Jake Schreier
doing some of the episodes.
He's doing Marvel's
Thunderbolts right now,
and he just did Steven Yeun's beef series.
Steven Yeun is going to play The Sentry
in the Thunderbolts movie in the MCU.
Bryce Dallas Howard is doing an episode
and David Lowery,
who just did the Green Knight.
So these have amazing directors
working on the series.
There were a bunch of other trailers
that they release, like a Star Wars
acolyte trailer.
I'll do a video for that next.
There was an extended
a soldier trailer with a big grand
Admiral Thrawn revealed
to also do a video for that as well.
I just did a much bigger video
explaining what the new Star Wars
movies are going to be
and when that's going to happen.
So click here
to learn about that in Click here
for my brand new Ahsoka trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.